madame monet que je suis une amie dit qu
il faut vraiment que je le vends je n'ai
pas vu mon fils depuis deux ans je ne
peux pas vous et il m'a pris mon énergie
écoutez je ne sais même pas qui vous est
fait tatouer son nom sur nos mains
portel et vous voulez quoi alors de
l'argent non pas quatre ou cinq bonnes
vous êtes la femme de ménage oui je vous
présente madison vous pouvez vous
occuperez écouter les enfants moi j'y
connais rien alors j'en ai marre c'est
pas vrai vous dit jamais combat en baver
autant quand je vois toutes ces bonnes
femmes à la télé dans la rue qui sont
seulement talent peut voir ja rule fall
à bosser steven j'ai eu le riz d'agnès
il m'a dit tu avais des papiers depuis
un bon bout de temps c'est pas je vais
te presser mais enfin si la faut que je
trouve nico je suis sa petite amie
tallulah ce bébé il est acquis celle ci
vous avez été prochain et nous vous en
aviez fait de me marier et de fonder une
famille et ça a donné quoi je crois que
j'ai échoué sur les deux plans je
m'appelle louisa qui n'est services de
protection de l'enfance
je fais ça tu es ce que je suis très
tous comme on peut juste été êtres
humains
si tu as des ennuis tu peux compter sur
moi ici c'est ta famille
quand j'avais 6 ans ma mère m'a fait
asseoir sur le perron et elle m'a dit de
l'attendre j'ai jamais revu ma mère je
crois que c'est mieux quand personne n'a
besoin de rien avoir confiance en
personne qui prennent vie
votre fille besoin de fonds
ça me rend complètement attaque et un
grandissant ils vous détestent et là on
vient vraiment dingue c'est super triste
pas résister
alors non
ok
nous aussi
le chimiste
ça secoue